you
all right let's give it another go ten
two against computer impossible I'm due
for a win let's see if I can make that
happen
okay I'm gonna shoot for c4 c5 maybe II
6 g6 okay oh I think so known to play
Bishop to b4 now this is really not the
structure I wanted I would much rather
Bishop before exchange dark square
Bishop sand then plant my pawns on dark
squares but something much different
here hmm I don't know how big a fan I
would be with pushing d5 I don't think I
get good games against the computer with
that so I'm looking at e3 let's go at e3
much more reserved approach a6 that
seems very slow
not really it's anticipating d5 d5 takes
takes and then there's a quick b5 hmm I
wonder Knight c3 or Bishop to e2 here
hmm I don't know that I want to bring my
night out just yet let's let's think
though Knight c3 yeah I don't see
anything wrong with Brinkley NIDA
actually I want to retain some options
my bishop in fact exactly this after d5
I don't know if I want to play my Bishop
to e2 just yet Bishop e2 takes bishop
takes o a 6 is gonna be useful in that
line as well I think I could actually do
similar lets let me also get an a3 and
look for ideas of capturing and then
expanding with b4 okay I have the
immediate takes 3 capture so I'm gonna
be working with an isolated pawn hmm
where to go with the Bishop d3 or e2
I'm gonna drop all the way back stay out
of the way of let's say c4 with tempo
hmm it's Castle and I'll certainly
consider captioning on this square only
after the Bishop has moved maybe even
right now though maybe even still at
this stage pretty symmetrical I capture
Bishop takes b4 but should be seven
still a move-up hmm what other candidate
moves are there here I think I have to
go with this capture let's get it in I
don't know that I could have really made
a useful move maybe a ch3 bot okay so I
need to get him developed so I think the
way to do that is with b4 I think both
of us do well to keep the tension
between the Queens and you know what's
being prep tonight here hmm
the big difference here after Bishop d7
is related to our King bishops I think I
have to get him here so let's get that
in you our King bishops are the big
difference here if he's right here right
now it's perfectly symmetrical
everything so this is the only
difference in the position I'm on move
clearly c5 is weak if I could manage a
dark square Bishop exchange and plop a
nut right here in c5 that would be nice
and so that's a bit off though hmm this
Knights ready to jump in here and after
recapture the bishop will be pinning my
knight to my bishop hmm
rooks are gonna be occupying the D file
soon rook after d8 I think I need to
find a good home for my queen hmm what
moves are there here Queen B 3 it's kind
of tough Queen B 3 this Knight move here
hitting at f3 a couple of times I think
I'd like to have after 95 a knight
exchange and then Bishop to f3 available
let's let's go with rook AC 1 first yeah
let's do that first and then we're gonna
have 95 no okay so it's still pretty
symmetrical except for these King
bishops mm useful move might be h3 where
this clean really go I wonder if I'm
Queen c7 I would have Bishop takes b5
takes Knight takes and I have a fork
might be available although on h3 Queen
c7 if Bishop takes b5 there might be
rook d8 threatening Bishop h2 grabbing
my queen I wonder what other candidate
moves their arm a bit hesitant to maybe
throw my knight in to d4 I don't want to
allow this Bishop to be unmasked so
easily I think I should go with this get
a useful move in okay so we have some
Knight move so my first thought is that
I could maybe now make use of my f3
Knight we were both fighting for these
dark squares so he's no longer eyeing
these squares out hmm I wonder where is
he going actually Knight f5 not quite
sure what that's doing how about I
occupy the center here 94 looking for
let's say Bishop here hmm Bishop
three my light squares are gonna be very
weak this bishop is much better than my
bishop here though huh I think I don't
need to release the pressure in the Sun
way Bishop f3 okay let's get some trades
in and I got to get my Queen off of the
same file as the rook so let's go with
this no I wonder if pawn takes is worth
something here hmm you know what if pawn
takes yes it's a flight square but I
think a knight arriving on this square
be very annoying so I think I need to
keep the structure as is and let's see
where exactly is this night going ball
for Knights offset one another I need to
get my F rook working get my king of it
over here and he really needs to go yeah
he definitely needs to go black does not
have a flight square just yet I cannot
allow the knight to get into c4 and so I
think I'm quite laminated with my reply
here taking the bishop does not work
because of Knight takes Knight first
with check so let's go with this and
then I believe take on d8 and then
Knight where this night is gonna be very
strong let's see what about about
exchanging rooks and then playing F for
exchange rocks F for Bishop takes Bishop
takes I could plant up on this square I
think I might go for that
yeah let's definitely go for this I'm
weakening my light squares but I should
have a strong Bishop on d4 and an active
rook okay believe I take like this
however hang on for a moment Bishop
takes there's gonna be rook c8 huh we're
gonna have a good a very good night
versus a bad Bishop situation I think I
need to keep the rooks
bored huh all right well let's do it
black still needs a flight square this
rook can't go to too too far
what's that night up to hmm
rook here looking to push that night
away and actually he'll go nowhere
look here f5 and that Knight is cemented
right in there huh tricky tricky spot
here rook d3 f5 I don't even know where
to go from that point roof d3 f5 Bishop
d4 there's Knight takes eath free I
think I need to go after the a pun and a
lot of the e pawn to get picked up hmm
very difficult yeah I I have to stay
active with my rook I think this is my
best opportunity it's not the best
direction to going against the computer
but I have to after a shoot for it still
needs a flight square I imagine f6 is a
good flight score now h5 is the better
one of course light square I was
thinking f6 to blunt this diagonal but
ok I can't play rook here to either
these squares because of Knight c4 hmm
that is a bug it's an if I approach with
my king
9 c4 oh forget about that 91 can you
have 291 man you know I don't have a
great square for my bishop either hmm
rooks ready to give a couple checks I'm
in a very difficult spot um let's get my
bishop to a safe square maybe no very
difficult spot rook here why not and I
think I have to go after upon I wonder
if there's it's worthwhile to insert a
check first before I go after this guy
on b5 hmm I'll play here right now so
rook takes pawn is gonna happen with
check or that Ike I need to stay clear
of any tricky Forks so let's go here
stay far away from the knight that was
my only move and gotta get that pawn I'm
on this guy hmm
my rook is gonna get trapped though rook
takes pawn Knight f5 Wow
my rook is killed that's not cool I
don't know how to save my rook takes
pawn Knight f5 I am in a losing position
here time is irrelevant Bishop d6 it's
very difficult to get my pawn rolling
hmm it's not gonna go for a rook trade
well let's just try it
Bishop d6 I guess very difficult spot so
although that pawns gonna fall with
check everything's crumbling now they
have a past age pawn they should get
right behind that pun I have to stick
around here to defend against this guy I
can't even get them pushing let's play
to a7 at least we'll be there to help
with the promotion Square mm-hmm I'll
step up I feel like I'm going in the
direction of getting mated it's gonna
happen pawn push Knight g3 ideas yeah I
have an idea let's get pushing rook B -
I'm not going anywhere I have to defend
here against a knight check on g3 oh
there's also that okay I got a play here
this isn't working I was thinking
there's a check I could take him still
man I'm getting flushed right away
that's ballgame h2 and that's a good
spot to resign this is game over
ouch I got crunched that was terrible I
wonder if my decision was pointing out
the big difference here was the King
bishops so I'm wondering at this point
here the decision to actually drop back
to e2 when questioned with b5 I'm
wondering if Bishop d3 is better staying
on this diagonal and making way for an
eventual knight hop into e4 or maybe
another way to look at it is to get in
and afford Vance you know I think during
the video during the game I was pointing
out that I wanted to stay clear of a c4
push with tempo like if I'm playing here
but I think that's that's a poor thought
because that would of course release the
pressure on my Center I would have a
two-to-one majority and then at least I
could look into this active plan with e4
maybe e5 I think this is a better choice
after b5 instead of coming all the way
back to e2 again that's where there was
the big difference here perfectly
symmetrical from this position here if I
have the bishop on d3 yeah it was kind
of tough because at this stage right
here if I did have my bishop on this
square I would really like to just throw
my knight in to e4 release my bishop put
pressure on f6 what just happen there
but yeah if my Fisher was here this is a
new move that would be possible but yeah
clearly wasn't working out but okay
lesson learned I'll maybe try for
another time with this variation with
the bishop planting up to d3 and see
well if that'll do a little bit better
anyhow I'll have to give this a go for
another time that's all
to do for right now and as always I hope
you got something on this video take
care bye
you